regresemos a la historia donde todos
intentan salir del dinero manejado en el
país para convertir la moneda del país
vimos en el vídeo pasado que he dejado
sus propios recursos si esto llegara a
pasar si de repente tenemos muchos bebés
que quieren ser convertidos a moneda del
país
entonces ya que todo el mundo tiene
miedo de convertir hacen vez de hacer lo
contrario porque creen que el país ve
está en malas condiciones entonces
tendríamos este desequilibrio y si se
deja manejar la situación por sí sola la
moneda del país se devaluaría y
necesitaríamos más veces para
intercambiar por cada a lo cual es otra
manera de decir que el valor debe se
devaluaría y eso puede ser bastante malo
especialmente si fuera un descenso
fuerte porque quizá sea un país que
necesita qué sé yo importa el petróleo
del resto del mundo o tal vez importar
con mira del resto del mundo imagínate
si se llegara a devaluar la moneda
dramáticamente sus importaciones
saldrían muy muy caras y las personas
en el doble por gasolina por comida por
cosas básicas así que tenemos un
escenario donde el banco central del
país ve activamente interviene para que
las tasas de intercambios se mantengan
estables y lo que hacen es podrían usar
reservas y lo pondré en azul lo pondré
en azul para simbolizar el país ven
ahora pueden usar esas reservas de que
han estado acumulando durante mejores
tiempos en vídeos pasados y toman esas
reservas que acumularon en vídeos
pasados en mejores tiempos como lo
quieras ver e intercala intentan
balancear la oferta de gas con la oferta
de ves vendiendo sus reservas y
comprando ves una manera de pensarlo
estar aumentando su oferta de as y
también están aumentando su demanda de
ves para vender sus reservas de as y
comprarán su propia moneda esto va a
funcionar mientras tengan reservas y
podrán estabilizar la situación para que
no suceda esto
pero el problema era y lo hablamos en el
vídeo pasado que las reservas se les
puede terminar no es tan fácil como que
digan ah bueno pues imprimimos dinero
del otro país de hecho no pueden hacer
eso es imposible así que tienen una
cantidad finita de dinero de reserva que
se les va a terminar lo que casi siempre
sucede el caso típico los especuladores
de divisas a menudo ven esto imaginan lo
peor dicen mira personas quieren salir
de esta moneda se va a devaluar si se
deja abandonada para que se arregle todo
solo pero el banco central del país ve
está intentando que no se devalúe la
moneda debe manejando bien las quintas
reservas que tienen de divisas del país
a lo que los especuladores de divisas
comenzarán a hacer dirán bueno pues yo
puedo entrar al país ven literalmente
puedo ir a un banco del país ve y puedo
pedir prestado divisa debe luego voy al
mercado de intercambio y lo convierto en
ese entonces pido prestado debe y los
convierte en moneda manejada en a
entonces yo pido bebé para convertir el
as y viendo esto de una manera
superficial que va a hacer esto
que la situación del banco central
empeore porque personas ni siquiera
guardaron ves y ya están pidiendo veces
para convertirlas en las están haciendo
despectivamente entonces lo que van a
hacer es construir una mayor oferta de
ves y aún más demanda por la cantidad
finita de as que van a cruzar al otro
país pero te preguntarás por qué los
especuladores están haciendo esto
piensan las dos situaciones que tenemos
por cualquier razón y luego lo voy a voy
a dibujar los dos casos caso uno por
cualquier razón el banco central ver es
capaz de mantener la divisa estable
entonces lo escribo la divisa se queda
estable y el otro caso caso dos es que
el banco central se queda sin reservas y
deben esencialmente dejar que las
divisas floten por sí solas y se
devaluarán entonces el banco central se
queda sin reservas y que el banco
central se quede sin reservas nos lleva
a que las divisas a que las divisas
floten
entonces pongo las divisas flotan y así
psd evalúa entonces el banco se devalúa
ahora si el caso uno llegara a pasar
entonces será el caso que mientras más y
más personas se apilan a la tragedia van
a querer salir de la moneda manejada en
el país vez entonces
aún así si esta situación llegara a
pasar el caso 1 los especuladores dirían
ok la divisa se estabilizó yo
simplemente desenredó mi asunto tomo mis
más cuando deba pagar mi deuda tomo mis
alas convierto en vez pago mi deuda y me
voy de vacaciones al gusto y bueno
dependiendo en lo que las tasas de
interés eran esto fue una pérdida mínima
entonces como aquí pérdida mínima y sólo
si había una diferencia en las tasas de
interés o cosas por el estilo entonces
mínima o no perdida pero qué pasaría si
el banco central se quedará sin reservas
sólo con el hecho de que los
especuladores hagan los ataques
especulativos pidiendo prestado el país
ve para convertirse dinero en el país
eso está cocinando que el banco central
se quede sin reservas aún más rápido
cuando hagan esto el banco central del
país ve los va a dejar convertir ellos
no saben a quién están comprando estos
estos ves con las divisas que tienen
entonces esto pasa si el banco central
se queda sin reservas el banco central
se queda sin reservas flotan y después
ve se devalúa y los especuladores de
divisas hacen una buena lana para ver
cómo funciona esto imagina que piden un
préstamo un préstamo de 100 veces eso es
lo que piden prestado y mientras que las
divisas son activamente intervenidas por
el banco central que quiere que no se
devalúen mientras todo esto pasa la tasa
de intercambio es de una por una vez
entonces eso es uno a uno entonces
pueden convertir convierten en el
mercado abierto
aquí convierten convierten y la única
razón por la que eso puede pasar con
esta tasa de intercambio es porque el
banco central está activamente vendiendo
as entonces pueden convertir a 100
ahora digamos que pueden hacer esto y
que el banco central se queda sin
reservas de as y cabo la devaluación
ocurre esto está pasando en una
conversión de una a igual a una vez pero
digamos que estos cuates se quedan sin
reservas las cosas se devalúan de ahora
vale mucho menos y nos vamos al futuro
donde ahora una a es igual a dos veces
tan pronto como esto suceda recuerda
estamos viendo este caso es lo que los
especuladores quieren que suceda si una
es de pronto equivalente a dos veces
porque el banco central ya no puede
intervenir está flotando a veces devalúa
entonces qué va a pasar estos partes
pueden tomar sus tiendas convertirlas
nuevamente una vez que todo está
flotando entonces van a convertir en
esta dirección en esta dirección
por cuántas veces pueden convertir ahora
lo pueden convertir por 200 veces
entonces 200 veces pueden ahora pagar su
deuda porque pidieron 100 veces
prestadas entonces - siempre es para
pagar deudas pongo aquí para pagar
deudas y así saben muy bien premiados
estos cuates ahora con una ganancia de
100 veces y eso es exactamente lo que
esperan y puedes imaginar este es uno de
esos intercambios que van a querer que
más y más personas hagan porque entre
más y más personas salten al vagón y
usen esta misma estrategia mientras más
rápido suceda que el banco central se
queda sin reservas esto de aquí el caso
2 va a ocurrir